good afternoon my name is adrian dicks
i'm bc's minister of health to my right
is dr bonnie henry bc's provincial
health officer sarakova 19 briefing for
friday january the 28th as you'll be
aware two years ago
was the date of our first briefing and
indeed the report of the first
case of kova 19 in british columbia and
it's certainly been a long two years or
this is as i understand it the 276th uh
briefing today
we're honored to be here uh on the
territory of the lewangan speaking
people of the songis and the esquimalt
first nations and with that it's my
honor to introduce dr bonnie henry
thank you very much and good afternoon
come through
can help us put where we are today in a
perspective
and can help us remember
a lot of what we have learned and
experienced together
i will start by saying we've all made
sacrifices and experienced loss in some
way but it has not been equal
across this province
i also want to acknowledge
that our covet journey has not been in
isolation and we also have many other
things that have affected us across this
province and from my perspective as well
the ongoing public health emergency of
of the toxic drug crises that has been
profoundly affected by covent 19 and by
the measures that we've put in place
across society
it is not possible to cover everything
today
but we have experienced and we have
weathered this storm together and i do
want to acknowledge that particularly
the the toxic drug crisis is one that we
need to
bear in mind through all of this
so in this two years of working together
two years ago today as minister dix
uh indicated we
stood before you to announce on our
first case of covet 19 and there was a
lot we didn't know that was the start of
our pandemic and since that time every
single one of us in bc and around the
world have been impacted
and i think the thing that we realize
very early on is that we are connected
impacted
and i think the thing that we realize
very early on is that we are connected
we are connected to the people in our
community that we may not have
recognized whether that's the person
working in our grocery store the person
collecting garbage health care workers
our pharmacists our child early
childhood educators our teachers
and we are connected globally
and what that tells us is what we've
learned is that what happens in places
like recently south africa what happens
in places like india iran
affect us and that continues to be the
case
we've also seen and will show that our
collective efforts your efforts have
saved countless lives and have made a
difference
so today
we have over half of our eligible
children five to 11 have received their
first dose of covet 19 vaccine
92.6
of people across british columbia have
received at least one dose of vaccine
and 90 have received their second dose
as well
we now have
977 people and we haven't seen the
numbers from today in hospital
with a covet positive test
and how did we get there
if we think through these last two years
the first
really solidified our our understanding
and
um
was a lot of unknowns but from the very
beginning
we
had a number of goals that we kept to
through this whole time
a pandemic response requires
extraordinary efforts to control it
because of the potential impacts
and a new pathogen and the things that
we need to understand to manage it is
something that we've experienced here
and globally
early on we set our goals for this
pandemic and those remain today and that
is to reduce morbidity and mortality so
sickness and death as much as possible
to protect our health care system
because we know if the health care
system gets overwhelmed then people who
have other issues as well are not able
to get the care they need and that has
impacts on our health
individually and as a community and very
importantly to minimize societal
disruption because we know that that
also has impacts on our health both our
mental health our physical health our
emotional health particularly over time
so as the slides i'm showing you today
will show we have stayed true to these
goals as we have learned and changed and
adapted and adapted again
and we need to continue to adapt
if we look at this slide that we've seen
many times the cumulative case rates
there has been no part of our province
that has not been affected by this
pandemic and some rates some places have
re had the burden of the impact at
different times and we've seen that in
the waves that we've been through as
well when we look at our daily cases by
age we see as well that not all age
groups are impacted the same through
every single wave that we've experienced
people who are in the 19 to 59 year age
group so that is people who
have children are working are part of
much more connected are the ones who are
most affected in terms of getting
infected with the different strains of
this virus that we've seen but it's not
the same impact across the board and
particularly since we've had vaccination
from the very beginning we know that
those people who are most likely to end
up in hospital to have severe illness or
to die from covet 19 have been people
who are older age has across the board
being the number one most important risk
factor for for having adverse effects
from this strain of the from every
strain of this virus
and we've seen that in hospitalizations
we've seen that in the tragic
outbreaks that we've had in long-term
care and nobody has suffered more than
our seniors and elders and we need to
pause and remember the impacts across
families and across communities in
british columbia
where we have lost so many particularly
of our seniors and elders
through this however
we have all worked together to make a
difference and it's meant using
different tools at different times
depending on what we were faced with
at the very beginning we took a lot of
measures
public health measures government
measures
we stood together by staying apart we
learned all about the importance of
distancing and hand washing and staying
away if we're ill and
things like the the measures that we
needed to do to connect with others in
our community even if it was remotely
and going outside the importance of risk
and where things were higher risk were
inside versus outside
we learned about
the things that we could do to protect
those in long-term care but we also
learned about the intense impact it had
on communities and on families when
people were isolated
one of the things that we have done and
we've put an
incredible importance on is working
together with our first nations health
authority and first nations communities
across british columbia but all
indigenous peoples
metis and inuit peoples indigenous
people living in community and living
away from home
and this recognizes that pandemics
throughout history have
disproportionately negatively affected
indigenous peoples
and i am reminded again and again that
elder pauline waterfalls words to us
about how
we have shown through these differential
impacts of pandemics through history the
strength and resilience of first nations
and we saw that again repeatedly in this
past two years
and the importance of self-determination
in allowing indigenous peoples and first
nations to protect their communities
we learned that different tools are
needed at different times and this is
reflected in our testing strategy which
has strength has changed multiple times
at the very beginning when we had a
brand new test
that was challenging to scale up where
there was difficulties in getting the
reagents that were needed we recognized
our global dependence on certain supply
chains
particularly from china not only for
testing but for also things like ppe
which became part of our lexicon early
on in this
and when we had limited
amounts of tests
particularly the the more accurate pcr
tests when we had limited testing
available we needed to focus on those
people who are more likely to have this
virus so that we could isolate find out
where it was spreading take measures to
prevent transmission
after our first wave
we focused on expanding our capacity to
do pcr testing and we changed our
strategy as we moved into our second
wave that happened in the fall and
winter of 2020 and then again into our
third waves and fourth waves so when we
started to see the variance of concern
like alpha and gamma and then of course
delta
and what we needed to do was find
anybody who had symptoms so that was our
our message to people was we knew now
that those tools that we had like case
management contact tracing were
effective for those strains of the virus
because we had time to find people so if
we could find people that when they had
mild symptoms earliest on onset of
symptoms or even asymptomatic if they
had been in contact with somebody who
had who was a case we were able to
control and manage the spread through
that the active use of case and contact
tracing
and that really
helped us get through
both the second third and the delta wave
where that became more and more
important
as things changed again
recently in
december of 2021 we had to change our
strategy again there are so many
intensity in the spread of omicron meant
that we needed to change our approach to
testing it was not possible to continue
with trying to test everybody our
capacity was overreached so that meant
we had to go back to making sure that we
had those accurate pcr tests available
for those people who needed them most
and we focused again symptom
symptoms based testing still but on
targeted populations and that's where we
are right now
this is the picture again of the same
progress that we've made through genome
sequencing and we started very early on
with genome whole genome sequencing in
british columbia and ramped up
some projects that we had been working
on for
quite a long time around the use of
whole genome sequencing and help us on
helping us understand the trajectory of
outbreaks and what it showed us early on
was that we had a lot of introductions
from a conference a dental conference
that was held from washington state from
europe we could we could pinpoint using
this whole genome sequencing where we
were seeing cases come in
through our particularly our third wave
in march and april we started to see
alpha and gamma and that's the purple
and orange in this really competing with
each other and we're one of the few
jurisdictions that actually had two
different types of these variants
in different areas of the province and
then of course that was replaced over
time with delta across british columbia
and more recently very rapidly delta has
been replaced by omicron if this is the
first time in history that we've been
able to actually follow the genetic
changes and mutations of a virus in real
time
so to go through this really quickly
much was unknown in our first wave and
much was unknown not just here but
around the world and we took
extraordinary actions because of the um
the the
the intensity of the um of the what we
were being faced with and the many
unknowns that we had
and we had a lot of questions would it
continue to spread would it become a
virus that spreads in the community
would it still be a possibility of
control and i think many of us around
the world thought there was still a
strong possibility of being able to
control this virus
up until the summer
and once we got to the summer of 2020
and this virus was still circulating and
still circulating in large amounts
particularly in some parts of the world
again it reminded of us of our global
connectedness and the realization that
we were going to have to manage this
that there was no way we were going to
be able to push it back into nature like
we did with cyrus co v1 for example
and i've we put up a few of the the
things that happened during this time
where we started to use
provincial health officer orders
to require people to take specific quite
extraordinary measures
as ways to try and deal with the
unknowns and the spread of this virus
and it worked
we did a lot in british columbia to
flatten the curve
and
in
the face of a lot of different disbelief
and anxiety and fear
and
unknowns
once we got through the summer there was
a lot of concern and questions that were
still there we knew a lot more but we
didn't know everything
we had concerns that
as we went into our normal respiratory
season in bc and in canada that we would
see a resurgence and of course that is
what happened
but what we also knew was the in intense
negative impacts of some of those
extraordinary measures that we had taken
and so we we
refocused and we prioritized some of the
most important activities in our
community particularly making sure
children were in school particularly
supporting child care and early
childhood educators and
we made that transition to supporting
workplaces to develop specific plans
that met the needs in their workplaces
so our covet safety plans became an
important tool that we had during this
phase to keep things open as much as we
could we also came to understand more
about layers of protection in different
settings depending on the risk in those
settings
and finally of course one of the most
important and wonderful days that we had
was the arrival of safe and effective
vaccines on december 9th was when the
first vaccine was approved for use in
canada and our first vaccine was given
on december 15 of 2020
and that was a very positive and
optimistic day and i can't say how many
times i've seen
the happy faces of people getting their
vaccine the relief the optimism that
that brought with it
even as we were moving through what
became our nether wave in the spring of
2021.
so we know we had our mass vaccination
clinics the positive energy that we knew
were making a difference in in
reducing the risk particularly to those
who are most effective based on age
our seniors and elders who we
prioritized across the province people
who were clinically extremely vulnerable
who had additional conditions like
immune compromising conditions
that made them more at risk of severe
disease we also had issues with supply
and we go back and think about the
challenges where we knew this virus was
increasing again with these new variants
of concern as well as our supply
constraints meant that we couldn't
vaccinate as many people as we wanted to
as quickly as possible and we took
some very
measured and thoughtful
decisions around things like extending
the interval between dose one and dose
two
so that we could get more people with a
higher level of protection sooner
and that also made a difference
at this time we were able to provide
testing for symptomatic people we had
vaccines at our disposal
and that is what got us through this
wave
once we
headed into the summer again
with our vaccine success
there was a lot of optimism certainly i
felt it that with these effective
vaccines we would reach a level of
immunity that could help us control and
manage this virus in a way that we
hadn't been able to up until then
could this be our last wave again we
were reminded of our global
connectedness
where we had
the
rapid emergence of yet another variant
of concern the delta variant
and the pattern again of increased
infectiousness meant that that level of
immunity we had with the vaccine program
that we had so far was not enough to
prevent this strain of the virus from
transmitting and it was causing more
serious infections more hospitalizations
more need for icu care particularly
people who had not yet had that
protection from vaccines
again we went back to the tools that
were working for us at the time making
sure we had testing available for people
around the province making sure we had
our case contact management teams ramped
up and working
the high risk settings increasing our
vaccination of people and we were very
successful with that
we also as we were challenged with delta
starting initially in regional areas so
through the delta wave where we had had
high vaccination and people were taking
these measures particularly in the lower
mainland we weren't seeing the outbreaks
that we were seeing in other parts of
the province and we know it was a
challenge primarily in the interior and
our northern health region
and then then in the end of november we
had our first five to 11
childhood vaccines and now
those children are coming up for their
dose too
the vaccination program has been immense
and tremendous and we've had such
participation we've had vaccination
rates that are
hardly imaginable
and to be able to have over 90 percent
of our population agree on the
importance of this type of a measure not
just to protect ourselves but
recognizing that what we do made a
difference it made a difference for our
families and our communities too
and the
wonderful
images that we have
of young people getting protected as
well and we need to continue to focus on
those
unfortunately we got
hit again
as we were weathering that wave of uh of
delta uh omicron came out of
of again the global connectedness that
we have
it was first detected globally or
reported on globally from south africa
and in late november
and by the middle of december it had
been detected and found all over the
world and it had spread rapidly
so we needed to adapt again and use the
right tools for the job that we were
faced with now which was an intensity
and a spread that was like
was very different from what we had seen
even with delta
and given this speed and intensity we
had to reset our control strategies and
respond differently
each of these waves has had their unique
challenges and our response has adapted
to that
we have made extraordinary societal
efforts and these efforts have saved
countless lives if we look at how we
have weathered these waves here in
british columbia we are managing to
prevent people from getting
needing hospital care
even as it has stretched our health care
system
and we have saved lives
there has been loss and there has been
much more of people affected in some
areas in some communities than others
and particularly as i said our seniors
and elders
so what is it that we can take from this
there have been five waves many variants
and likely many more to come
we are in this omicron era and we are
coming through it
but because the virus has changed we
need it to reset our control strategies
contact tracing is not something that
works with this degree of spread and
it's not possible to test everyone so we
need to focus our testing on those
people where we need it most but we do
know there are tools that we have that
do make a difference and that are
working
we have done the right thing
people have made sacrifices we got
vaccinated you supported your family
your friends your neighbors your
community
and right now the actions we need to
take
are clear to us
we need to get boosted that helps us now
that helps us for our longer term
protection
we need to get our children vaccinated
to protect them and make sure they can
continue to participate in the
activities that are so important for
their growth and development in health
we need to stay home when we're sick we
need to wear masks we need to keep our
groups small right now until we get
through this wave two and we can look
ahead to
a time when we have enough immunity and
we have enough control that we can start
to open up again and we can take these
extraordinary measures away
as we move through this phase the
extraordinary measures will change and
we're looking now towards the middle of
february and family day when we can
start to get back to doing some more
things
again this is about recognizing that we
have been on an incredibly arduous and
long journey and no i didn't think we
would be on this phase of the journey
for this long
but it is the reality that we have to
accept and so much has happened in those
last two years but we have the tools and
the resources and the wherewithal
to to help us deal with whatever is
going to lie ahead
we know
um
that
i lost my dream about here
we know that covent 19 will be with us
for some time it's not done with us yet
new variants will surely emerge
immunity will wane whether that's from
infection or from vaccination and we
know that there's a seasonality and next
fall will bring the increased risk of
transmission again
and we need to prepare for that
but
we do know that we can get through this
and we will reach a point where we no
longer need public health orders where
we no longer need those extraordinary
societal efforts
and we can
rely on each other to do those
individual and collective things that
make a difference
this last two years
i have not been alone in this journey we
have not been alone there have been an
incredible group of people who have been
around us and helping us make these
decisions and i want to thank all of
them for the work that they have done
and continue to do each and every day in
particular i want to recognize my public
health colleagues across the province
the team at the bccdc the pho office
and thank you to all of the healthcare
workers everywhere who have not stopped
who have stepped up and provided care
for everyone every day for this last
very long period of time
and i will also say today one of my dear
friends and colleagues is retiring and i
want to
say my thanks and gratitude to dr
richard stanwick here in vancouver
island
and of course thank you to everybody in
british columbia in your own unique way
every person in this province has been
part of the team that has stepped up and
done our part
we followed public health guidance we
flattened the curves
and that has saved lives
you have been kind and calm
and compassionate with each other and
that has made it safer for everybody
every day
so while we must continue to persevere
in this phase of our journey
we need to acknowledge the challenges
and loss
let's find hope in knowing that our
collective action has made a difference
and will continue to make a difference
and i'll turn it over to minister dicks
thank you very much dr henry and
i wanted to
start by
by just expressing my thanks to
all of our healthcare teams across the
province from dr henry and her
teams in public health
people working acute care and home
support and long-term care in our
pharmacies
people are working in the community
the extraordinary teams that are working
to support people
through the public health emergency that
is the overdose crisis which continues
star was declared in 2016 and continues
and has been
exacerbated by the kova 19 public health
emergency i think our teams have been
exceptional and i am
honored to
work alongside them
as we deal with these two public health
emergencies and all the other challenges
facing our health care system
since the first wave of covet and all
the way through there have been moments
when a shift was needed a change was
required when a difference had to be
made
and all along fundamentally
the difference for all of those health
care teams and all of us
we made the difference that matters each
of us
all of us
every single time and that difference is
all about all around each of us
we see it in mass worn physical
distancing kept coveted sense used
health orders respected health guidance
embraced
we see it in vaccinations developed and
then received by us
and by our children
in boosters offered and accepted
in all the work we do to make the
difference that's required
this is bc we fight covet and all that
it tries to take we fight to make things
better safer to ensure our resilience
and the durability of all that we count
on our work is not done
in this moment in our pandemic a time of
great challenge for patients waiting for
their surgeries a time of great
challenge for all we count on for our
public health care a time of great
challenge on many fronts we must perform
our job with the same dedication and
drive we have demonstrated since the
start
with that i just want to note
especially with respect to vaccinations
i want to encourage people to book their
vaccines today when invited they remain
just uh as we noted on tuesday 48 000
people 70 plus who have received their
invite but have not yet
booked a booster it's urgent that these
the this group of people that these
folks get vaccinated as they are more
likely to be hospitalized if they
acquire covid19
there are
670 000 as of yesterday people who have
been invited for their boosters and have
not yet booked that's people 18 plus
we strongly encourage them to book into
our clinics or pharmacies today
yesterday 31 000 people did so thirty
one thousand five hundred eighty one
percent online nineteen percent over the
phone but there were as of yesterday six
hundred thousand appointments open
across the province we encourage people
to fill those appointments and in
addition we encourage parents of
children 5 to 11 to register and book
the vaccine for their children today we
have passed the 50 50 mark in terms of
vaccines administered
to
children 5 to 11 uh five fifty-five
percent of children five to eleven are
uh vaccinated or booked at the moment
but we strongly encourage parents to get
children in this age group vaccinated
with their first dose and now with 27
000 invites to people who had their
vaccine after the eight week interval
their second dose as well and you see
those numbers in the thousands starting
this week
this is critical this is what we can do
now especially to contribute to both our
collective effort but also to contribute
contribute to our own safety in these
times our safety from being hospitalized
our safety from severe outcomes our
support for one another and making
ourselves and our communities safer i
strongly encourage you to book your
vaccine today the get vaccinated website
or
1-833-838-2323 call in and book your
appointment
in the past two years and you've seen
this since dr henry has presented today
we've blazed our own path a path that's
marked by consideration for others by
generosity and by compassion by
tolerance by hard work by relentless
work like focused work
these are the qualities that mattered
two years ago they matter today and they
will matter no matter what the pandemic
and the future bring our our way because
our work is not done
yesterday in our health in
our acute care hospitals across the
province there were
9231 patients
in patients across our systems we have
as you know
9229 base beds and 2 353 surge beds in
our system but it is a significant
challenge and
that's why it's so important that we all
stay involved in supporting public
health guidance public health orders and
getting vaccinated in terms of critical
care there are 510 critical care beds
218 surge beds yesterday there were
474 people in critical care including in
the last couple of days an increasing
number again of unvaccinated people
vaccinated against cova 19 who are
dealing with covet 19 in critical care
units all over bc
and i'd say finally that
what got us today to where we are today
and the work that we've done today over
the last two years work we've done
together as a province in dealing with
will get us to tomorrow and beyond and
it's not just in stopping the spread of
covet but through our essential work
required to renew rebuild and add new
strength and resilience to our health
care system the skilled and caring
people who deliver it and the key and
essential parts of it that matter so
much to each of us and to all of us from
mental health and addictions care to
primary care from neonatal and maternity
care to surgical renewal acute care
long-term care palliative care all of
the things we do in the community and
all the things we need to do together to
address the social determinants of
health for the ministry of health and
for me this work will like our surgical
renewal action start with a clear
assessment of the challenges then a
clear path to address them each of them
and because sometimes plans fall through
we will make the achievement of those
plans a commitment a commitment to
patients their families and those who
love and care for them and then as we
have done with our surgical renewal
commitment we will fulfill those
commitments as well
this is an effort that will be led in
british columbia by our premier whose
commitment
to ensuring that at all levels of
government we work together to deliver
the health care that people in canada
need and deserve will be there
the work that the premier is leading
with respect to a renewal of the canada
health transfer is critical to that and
it's work that we need to focus when we
focus on that work is focusing on
patients and people and their health
care needs that's important not the
jurisdictional needs of governments and
all of the debate that goes on but
focusing on people that's what we will
do in all of these areas of healthcare
as we continue to deal with the covet 19
pandemic we will ensure a bc health care
system that is renewed
rebuilt and strengthened after two years
of enormous challenges with the pandemic
and other challenges facing our our
system and our society the kinds of
things that we have seen in the last two
years including moving hundreds indeed
combined thousands of people in
long-term care having to move them
because of wildfire and flood
all right we need to do that because it
is a the public healthcare system has
again as it always does demonstrates it
demonstrated its value to all of us and
we must demonstrate our belief in its
value by continuing to support and
invest in supporting a new generation of
healthcare workers in short our work is
not done not with the pandemic
and not with the public health emergency
that's the overdose crisis
and not with our need to invest and
support our health care system
and with that it's my honor to take it's
our honor to take your questions
a reminder to reporters on the line
please press star one to enter the queue
you'll be limited to one question and
one follow-up our first question today
comes from gordon hoekstra vancouver's
son
good afternoon thanks for taking my
question um just wondering uh if you
could expound a little bit more on what
you mean by uh you know things could
change or even a different place by
family day on february uh 21st does that
mean lifting restrictions or are you
talking about just you know bending the
curve more and hospitalizations being
down
i'm talking about all of those things
you know we are making our way through
this omicron wave it is different yet
again and there are measures that we put
in place in december to address some of
those higher risk settings and to give
us time to understand omicron more so
yes we are seeing the peak i hope
in our hospitals right now there is a
strain on our hospitals we don't expect
to see the census drop for some time but
we're also at a point where
much in the community is changing and
people have a level of immunity because
we've stepped up for booster doses so
yes we the
the orders the most recent orders are
due for review
on
february 16th and before february 16th
on february 15th we'll be talking about
those and if we are continuing on this
trajectory then yes i do hope that we
will be able to lift some of those
restrictions and gradually get back to
those needed connections that we have as
you know most of the restrictions right
now are on social gatherings and social
connections and i
um and looking at family day as a time
to start getting back to
not opening things up completely because
we know and we've seen that around the
world that when you do things
precipitously you can get a rebound that
can be
really
hard on people so
hard on us because we start to see more
transmission again so what we will do
and we've been working with the
different sectors who are affected about
plans for a gradual reopening and coming
back together and i see family day is
one of those
next steps
gordon do you have a follow-up
i do um you mentioned i think both
yourself mr dicks mentioned about
encouraging people you know whether it's
children to eleven their parents to book
them and get a vaccine or on the booster
side um is there anything that the
province can do in terms of uh
initiatives or whatever to try and uh
you know trying to move that forward i
mean i see that bc is behind some
provinces on on both of those uh fronts
yes so we are well on the booster dose
front we're actually in a pretty good
place but you're right and we have been
doing a number of initiatives for for
children particularly 5 to 11.
we've been working with children's
hospital and there was a number of
webinars and other things yesterday
working with family docs about how we
can make it
make it part of their
role involve them more in providing
vaccinations for
for young children i think that's really
important thing in certain communities
we're reaching out through schools to
give opportunities for younger children
and
all school-age children so there's a
whole variety of things we are doing on
that in terms of boosters i think
there's a there's a
you know we've seen that infection
spreads rapidly amongst that highly
connected younger age group um i will
also say that the the 18 to 29 age group
is the one that has under after 80 plus
where we have 90 percent
in the very high 90s of people getting
their their booster doses um that young
people are stepping up and getting
vaccinated and that's made a huge
difference in post-secondary
institutions in workplaces and other
places and i need to encourage all of
you to get your booster it's not only
for now
these booster doses we now know are
especially after that six-month interval
and there's a study that was published
just
at least i read it yesterday it came out
in the last few days
that really supports that that six month
or at least five to six month interval
between
second dose and the booster dose
again gives longer lasting protection so
that's going to help us
with whatever comes next so we don't
have to have some of the measures in
place again that we've had to see in the
last few weeks and months
so
yes everybody step up get your booster
dose it's good for you it's good for
getting us out of this pandemic and
getting us out of this wave and it's
going to be important for us for what
comes next
next question maria weisgarber ctv
hi there i just wanted to ask
following up the announcement last week
about the 200 000
rapid tests that were going to be sent
out for
educational workers in the k-12 sector
um checking around with some districts
today in metro vancouver and anecdotally
have heard that some districts seem to
have their tests and others don't yet so
i was just curious what the status of
the rollout is and will the province be
looking to secure more rapid tests for
the school community beyond this initial
amount
the answer to the second question is yes
absolutely as they're coming in what we
would like to see is um right now
they're they're the target is some
supporting staff and and teachers and
staff in those settings to to make sure
if they have symptoms that they have an
option of getting tested to understand
what's happening
but yeah once we get a larger supply and
i've said this for several months what
we would like to be able to do is
provide them to parents so that you can
make those decisions for your child if
they have symptoms on any given day and
well that's part of the plan in terms of
rollout i know that they've gone out to
each of the
school districts and i don't know you
have more information on that on the
operations and logistics
see yes they've gone out in their
hundreds of thousands they'll continue
to go out just to give you an update on
where we are as of january 27th uh
bc has received about seven seven
million five hundred twenty eight
thousand rapid tests we've deployed five
million seven hundred and thirty seven
thousand of those
uh that leaves a current inventory of
one point seven nine one million
five hundred ninety seven thousand of
which we've received over the last few
days so those are received and then
processed and moved out
as you know about 556 000 of that
inventory aren't suitable for deployment
or take take away use and just to give
you a sense of where we are this week
this week we'll be delivering over 1
million 666 000 test kits including on
those those on hand and expected new
test kits arrivals as follows
351 thousand to cover the 19 test sites
250 000 to replenish supplied acute care
centers 260 000 to support the testing
of visitors and symptomatic staff and
long-term care and symptomatic staff and
assisted living 130 000 to support
remote rural and indigenous communities
300 000 additional tests to support k-12
education 375 000 to support business
and organizations as part of the
pointless care testing process and over
250 000 rapid tests are in the process
of being delivered to the child care
sector as you know and i think laid out
on tuesday we were expecting between
today in the middle of february
about 10 and a half million rapid tests
that's a reduction in what we expected
but still a considerable amount and as
and as those tests come in they'll be
distributed to key priority areas and
k-12 education is clearly one of them
maria do you have a follow-up
thank you yes uh also relating to
part of the announcement last week along
with the uh rapid tests for schools uh
it was mentioned that there would be
additional funding coming to uh support
further upgrades and improvements for
ventilation in k-12 schools that that
would be made available soon um in
addition to the investments that have
already been made so what's uh what is
happening with that uh new uh money
that's expected for those types of
upgrades
yeah i'm afraid you're going to have to
refer that to the ministry of education
obviously they're the people who know
all the details of those funding
announcements i know that they're
working very hard on that and that
there's been an initiative and every
school has been assessed
but i can't give you the details of that
specific announcement
next question goes to richard zusman
global news
uh dr henry with nasi's changing
guidance today around boosters for 12 to
17 year olds where is the province at
with offering that age group the
boosters and to the larger issue today
you know as we plan towards
family day and easing those restrictions
what do you say to the most vulnerable
who
won't be able to keep up
in terms of
their risk will still very much exist as
many people are just moving on
yeah you know it is all about balance
and
that is why we
still have things in place and why we
reinforce as i've mentioned we reinforce
the importance that each of us does
around reducing risk in in our own
family in for ourselves for our family
our community so as each of us gets
vaccinated it makes a difference in the
amount of virus that's circulating in
our community and that in itself
protects those who are most vulnerable
and yes people who have these innate
vulnerabilities whether it's because of
the immune system because it's cancer
treatments because of age and underlying
illnesses we all need to take additional
measures to protect them and they need
to continue to take additional measures
to avoid some of the higher risk
settings until the virus is able to is
at a low enough level so it is going to
be different for each of us based on our
risk of the activities that are that
we'll be able or want to partake in
and the measures that we'll need to use
as we have less and less hopefully of
this virus circulating so it really is
titrating our own risk with the measures
that we know work and the situations
that we're going to be in so rate now
the important thing is that all of us
need to continue to take these active
measures whether it's vaccination and
masking and keeping our group small
because that's how we are dampening down
the amount of virus that's transmitting
and that protects everyone
in terms of
the nasty statement for uh
12 to 17. that is something that we've
been discussing and we're expecting
so we've been discussing with our bc
immunization committee and looking at
you know what this means for our program
here and we have another meeting with
as i mentioned today that we have a
large team um that we work together on
these issues and find out what is you
know think through what is the best way
to approach this from bc's perspective
and we'll be
coming out with our plan
starting sometime next week so next
tuesday i'll be able to talk to it in
more detail so
we're also looking at
you know the information that nasa used
to make those decisions
as well as what other jurisdictions are
doing around the world so
there's lots of pros and cons and i'll
be uh talk more about some of those
details next week
richard do you have a follow-up
this week dr henry we saw some of the
highest days of covert related deaths
who is still dying here are these cases
linked to long-term care
and
you know is enough being done to prevent
these deaths from happening and for
minister dick's unrelated to covid uh
there's been another
uh clinic closed in victoria in terms of
family doctor support what is the
province doing to address a shortage of
family doctors and to support you know
hundreds if not
more people who no longer have a
connection to the to the primary care
system
yeah you know the people who die
from covet and with covet has always
been
part of the tragedy of this pandemic it
is something that we've been watching
and measuring in a way that we don't for
many other
illnesses so yes about 40 percent of the
people who've died in this month
have been related to
outbreaks in long-term care
most of the people who are dying outside
of those outbreaks are older people with
underlying illnesses
a high proportion of them are people who
don't have the protection from
vaccination we have had younger people
die as well some of that are people who
were infected with delta
we know that it caused more severe
illness and it's people who've been in
hospital for some time for example and
some of it is the fact that this virus
even in its uh form that it is now the
omicron
strain does cause severe illness in some
people so most of the younger people
that we've had at least this week
two people in their 40s who've died
from covid we've had younger people
as well and
younger tend to be people who are not
yet vaccinated and don't have that
protection and many have other
underlying causes as we know
but age is the number one most important
risk factor in about 40 percent of
people are people in long-term care and
we have talked a little bit about what
we're seeing in long-term care right now
because we have such high rates of
vaccination in
in residence and in staff and high rates
of booster doses we're seeing very mild
illness but we count everybody who has a
positive cova test and dies within 30
days of that test as being
we we've always
recognized that
kovit could play a role in those
people's deaths unfortunately
so
obviously um there are significant
challenges uh facing especially in some
parts of the problems our primary care
system
one of the key challenges is that
fundamentally
the system that has been in place for
the support and funding of private
primary care
is not best suited to the current times
and that's why we've been undertaking a
transformation well before kovit in fact
since 2017 of our primary care system
focusing on team-based care
so you've seen the development of more
than two dozen urgent and primary care
centers but also dozens of primary care
networks which support our existing
primary care systems not to the side but
our existing systems including here on
the south island creation of new
community health centers
the the addition of additional supports
for first nations uh
led primary care initiatives as well so
you see that in a move to team-based
care allowing a variety of health care
professionals to work to the full extent
of their skills
we've also seen
compared to other jurisdictions in
canada an increase in family practice
doctors relative to other jurisdictions
but there are significant challenges our
existing system
is based uh when a clinic closes and
that's happened and this is particularly
an issue in the south island it's a
great worry for people particularly
people with chronic diseases who are
older who need health care services and
that's why we're doing a lot of work
right now here on the south island with
local divisions of family practice to
address these problems because it's not
just creating new services which do
support us and have been invaluable
during the covet 19 pandemic and
building out team-based care but it's
also important to stabilize systems so
that work is being done with local
doctors now i want to emphasize that our
core initiative in reforming primary
care are primary care networks which
come from local divisions of family
practice so this involves working with
doctors and we've done succeeded in
doing this
in uh in almost 50 communities across bc
in community health service areas across
bc where proposals from local divisions
of family practice from local nurse
practitioners come forward and those
proposals are supported and funded and
as a result more than 800 new staff have
been added to support primary care
across the province which is a
significant achievement there is more to
do
on the south island we're working
closely with family practice doctors to
address the present situation represent
some of the challenges that covet 19 has
brought here and that's true across bc
as well so that's the work that's
happening now there is a significant
initiative in place clearly more needs
to be done and we're acting on that as i
noted in my initial remarks
for the next question we go to xiaozu
globe and mail
hi dr harry uh the definition of an
outbreak in long-term care homes appears
to have changed
how are long-term care homes deciding
when an outbreak is declared and what's
the threshold vsth told us
outbreaks continue to be declared by a
medical health officer if there is a uh
higher than ex expected level of
transmission what does that higher than
expected level mean could you please
specify that
yeah so yes
and i've said this several times we uh
it is the medical health officer in the
local situation that works and assesses
uh the uh the situation in every
long-term care home that has always been
the case and the declaration of an
outbreak is at the discretion of the
medical health officer based on the
unique situation in every home
so you will remember that very early on
in this we used our outbreak guidelines
and they're available we've had them for
a long time respiratory outbreaks and
long-term care
guidelines
that were based on things like influenza
and we found that early on in dealing
with covid
that it was sometimes causing especially
early on causing mild disease in many
people so we lowered the threshold for
making sure that we were being very
sensitive and detecting every single
case
with omicron it's changed again and it's
changed
in several ways one of them is that
we're seeing in the highly vaccinated
population that we have now in care
homes
that it's not causing
the same amount of illness so we've gone
back again to looking at and the
definition of an outbreak this is
something we use in epidemiology all the
time it is a number above expected so it
depends on what expected is and with
what we're seeing transmission in the
community it's around seeing
a clinical illness that is severe enough
to cause
medical
concern for a resident so we are seeing
a lot of uh staff in particular this is
what we're seeing across the board that
staff are are infected they're infected
in the community they have mild illness
many of them are off for a period of
time so the the level of exposures that
we're seeing is different and the
severity of illness we're seeing is
different in long-term care so i've said
this before and we'll be coming out with
the published guidelines but we are
working through what this means in terms
of consistency in declaring outbreaks
across the province but we are still
managing every single facility and it's
not based on a specific number it's
based on the clinical situation in each
facility
xiao do you have a follow-up
yes i do thanks so because the
definition is shifting so is it the same
across all health authorities and also
because the restrictions are being
relaxed in the general uh public how
long do you expect care homes to have to
severely restrict visitors
yeah so we have changed the visitors so
that we recognize the impact that that
has had on on long-term care homes so
that they can continue to have
visitation and that's one of the things
that's different about managing
outbreaks now compared to uh over the
last few years and partly that's making
sure that everybody does have a visitor
if they want one
and particularly to support them when we
have
so much transmission right now that's
not causing severe illness so those
things have changed and yes the guidance
is consistent it's all based on the
clinical judgment that we are doing
consistently across the province and
we're
catching up with the documentation of
that and we'll have that
out for people soon but it is important
what we are doing now is balancing what
we're seeing on the ground in terms of
clinical illness with the restrictions
that we had in place quite
extreme restrictions and recognizing
that that also has health impacts for
residents and care homes so finding that
balance based on the situation in each
care home
next question goes to justin wong singh
tao daily
yes hi
yes yes i think thank you for dr henry
and that they said both of these be with
us these two years so i want to ask
about to the gay person or the lgbt
person in vancouver because they think
that they will be difficult to get the
service for him or other organizations
because the common knight team they
think about the government they focus on
the covert knight team but
they will get any service
from from the organization how to think
about this issue
yeah so i'm i'm not sure exactly in
terms of what services we're thinking
about i do know that
it is an area that obviously we have
seen that this pandemic along with many
other things differentially affects
certain communities and the lbgtq
community is one of them where
yes it can be very challenging
to
to
deal with some of the issues that we're
seeing in accessing health services i
will say that we have uh focus on many
uh of the services that are needed and
the bccdc some of my colleagues working
with the uh the programs at bccdc have
been focused on that but i'm i'm not in
i don't know particularly what what the
concern is i'd be happy to talk with you
offline
to understand what exactly
we're looking at here justin do you have
a follow-up
yes
because they said they're very difficult
to get the hiv broadcast and the hpv
vaccine they have to ask for the puppy's
house or their family's daughter because
as many many years ago they
they are very easy to get in the
communities of organization for for
example the him yes so
now they are they are very difficult to
get the
this uh service for example the pidp
yes
i i actually had not heard that because
i know i obviously know him very well
and and uh some of the the center for
excellence and hiv and aids and the work
that has been done
through our community at uh through the
clinics at bccdc so i'm happy to take
that back and discuss with our
colleagues about where the issues are
i had not heard that that was a an issue
so obviously really important services
to make sure that people with hiv get
what they need and
don't have disruptions in their access
to to medications and treatments so
thank you for bringing that up
yes i expect shortly to do an update
with dr montana in the center for
excellence for hiv aids in bc but i
think it's fair to say that we continue
to lead the way and
having seen
the update and we will be reporting out
on programs such as the prep program
which have been exceedingly successful
led by
dr montana and their team so i'll be
interested to hear
and be able to respond to issues you may
have at that time but i can
let you know that you can expect an
update on that in detail
very soon and i think it's fair to say
given the quality of the work being done
there that it'll be very positive upset
update and show
what we're doing in british columbia and
i think what we need to do around the
world as well to deal with hiv aids
we have time for one more question we'll
oh
go ahead just to say you know
you took me a little bit by surprise
with that question but uh you know we
have been working very closely with
our group in terms of identifying people
who may be more at risk and we've
prioritized for many people
in that community
to be able to receive their vaccines
sooner
as well
recognizing particularly people who are
living with hiv that
that can be a risk factor for more
severe illness
we have time for one more question we'll
go to bell pury cbc
dr henry at the start of your comments
today you said looking back helps to put
things into perspective so two years
into the pandemic
uh what
is there that you and minister dicks
wish that british colombia had done
differently you know
what are your regrets and in english and
french please
yeah i'm not sure i'm at the point where
regrets are what we need um it's more
about looking at how we adapted as we
did
and recognizing that uh it change is
difficult and it's hard and you know
it's easy to look back and say oh well
that was obvious it was coming
but when you're looking forward and you
don't know how high the wave is going or
when it's going to start or when it's
going to decrease
it is a very different perspective and i
was trying to
remind us all that there are many things
that were unknowns that we now
take for granted in some ways and that
we were very focused on specific tools
that served us well through much
but now
as we're changing
or as we're seeing a new virus that has
changed a new strain of the virus that
has changed
those old tools that served us well are
not
are not working anymore and we need to
find new tools and new strategies and
that there is hope that this movement
through this phase of it is going to
push us to that point where we no longer
need to take those extraordinary
you know public health measures and
societal measures to be able to live
with this virus and manage it
effectively in the future
i think if i regret anything sorry
it's really that
my challenges in
being able to communicate when we've had
major changes and to communicate why we
need it to change things in a way that
was
accessible to everybody and
that continues to be the challenge and
one of the things of
doing this today was to try and and put
some perspective around
the language that we've learned and how
we've moved
ahead with it and
reassuring people that we have learned a
lot and i guess
if i could do anything over it would be
to be
be clearer in some of those
communications particularly at those
most stressful times when things are
changing
i think
what i'd say bill is we're right and
still
in the middle of this in this moment of
the covet 19 pandemic and still working
hard
to both support people
we have
about 900 and i think was 977 people in
hospital yesterday
it'll be i think about the same today or
just slightly higher
and so this is a moment where we're
right in the middle of supporting our
health care systems and supporting one
another i think what i would say is that
there's there's always uh
an assessment after the fact but i think
what i find
so impressive about dr henry and her
approach and her whole team's approach
is
is not to be stuck but to continue to
learn every day and adapt every day
and
because when the pandemic came and
kova 19 came on the scene there was
enormous things we didn't know and
decisions were based on less knowledge
and now they're based on more knowledge
but this is
this is a team of public health leaders
who is never stuck
who always looks at the evidence looks
at the facts never worries about
whether we need about whether changing
will reflect on the past decisions but
change when it's necessary to protect
people i'm very very
really proud of our public health teams
of our whole teams in healthcare for
their willingness to do that and i think
that's been reflected
in the general public
which has been overwhelmingly responsive
a lot of our focus is people because the
vast majority of people have been doing
exactly what they've been asked to do
the vast majority of people of course
have been vaccinated there's a tendency
to focus a lot on on those who aren't or
those who are not following and state
everyone this is true for all of us is
that um
it's not it's not too late to join it's
not too late today is the best day if
you haven't been vaccinated to get
vaccinated
and
the assessments and the reflections well
we're right in the middle of this right
now and the the
omicron a wave of the covet 19 pandemic
bc has had relative to other
jurisdictions some success but there's
also been real losses
and rather than focus on my regrets i i
think of all the families who've lost
people from covet 19 all the people
affected by culver 19's impact on the
overdose public health emergencies the
health care workers who work so hard the
grocery workers and other essential
service workers
i look at them as a sense of pride and
support of course but also an
understanding of what so many people
have lost in the last two years and
that
that sense of
of
shared grief also drives us forward at
this point
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bell do you have a follow-up
i do yes please um with half of the five
to 11 year old children in the problem
still not vaccinated we're seeing some
pushback from parents and teachers on
the announcement earlier this week that
youth sports tournaments will come back
at the start of uh
early next week so should we expect to
see an increase in in transmission and
if so are you okay with that and if
you're not expecting the numbers to go
up why not and in english and french
please
just apropos of your last question i was
thinking of
maya angelou who says you know
do the best with what you know and
this is a poor paraphrase do the best
with what you know and when you know
better do better and i think that's
always been our mantra with my team
about trying to adapt to what we know as
we go um
yeah i was actually a little taken by
surprised by that uh we know that um for
some children that uh activities in
sports and and dance and other things is
a really important important part of the
growth and development and as you know
we have prioritized youth sports and
activities
for that very reason i think as adults
we can give up a season of having our
old timers hockey tournament but as
children those can be really important
important
events for them
so we have prioritized them
we have measures in place and we worked
with via sport to make sure that
those are uh told
are out there with all of the leagues
we've worked together a lot through this
pandemic we meet regularly with uh the
multiple sports leagues for especially
for children and youth and so yes i do
expect
that
that they will be followed that we have
those guidance in place it involves
making sure that the adults in those
settings are
you are vaccinated and doing the right
things and
so i don't expect there to be a large
increase in cases i do know that some of
the school tournaments
that the school system and and teachers
and
the school districts are working
together on whether those are viable
right now or not and that's more because
of what we are seeing
that there are strains on our
schools across the province because of
uh staff being off with the illness
particularly and we've seen some
functional closures so
that is up to the school system to try
and determine what's the best way to
manage
school based sports and and competitions
but i don't expect to see an increase in
transmission related to youth sports
and i expect that everybody will
follow the the guidelines that we've put
in place to try and do our best to
minimize any risk
and just to say you know um youth of
course uh represents those 15 16 17 and
18 and if you look at the data that we
look at every day at 17 and 18 year olds
and 16 year olds have some of the
highest levels of vaccination of any age
cohort in the province and
i think it's important especially in
sports where it's possible
and there are the practical
considerations in school sports that
dr henry has spoken about that we
returned to that with everyone following
the covet safety plans that need to be
in place for those events to be
successful and so i want to acknowledge
that a lot of people
people involved in sports in bc and a
lot of people who sort of graduate from
sports systems whether it be
12 year olds for little leagues or six
17 or 18 year olds for let's say
coming up would be the
high school
basketball tournaments and
in bc these are important moments in
their lives and some people have lost
those moments in the last couple of
years and so
it's important that we act safely and
follow public health guidance but it's
also
important that these events take place
if they can be done safely and so
that's the direction
that public health is given here and i
think it's a good direction giudice
is
you
thank you very much